let's do a quick uh look through a
recent
press conference that republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green gave
as we talked about earlier in the week
she now has apologized and said you know
when i compared stuff to the holocaust
that was wrong there's nothing like the
holocaust she learned at age 47 that the
holocaust is really bad
and some people thought hey you know
what she seems sincere maybe things are
going in the right direction with
marjorie taylor green
very much not at all here she is
yesterday being asked have you been
vaccinated and check out what she says
i stand with the americans that want
their privacy
and hipaa gives us gives us rights to
privacy
with our medical information and so i
appreciate you asking but that
is my right to keep my medical
information private
so understand that hipaa has nothing to
do
with journalists asking her questions
this is being used
frequently by the right and sometimes
these talking points just they get
they get ahead of steam it's like a
runaway train hipaa hippa sean hannity
said the same thing
on his show a few weeks ago he said you
know i was going to talk about my
vaccination decision
but all these people now are asking me
have you been vaccinated and hipaa
medical privacy
hipaa relates to medical providers and
your information
and the safe keeping of it doctors can't
say whether you are or aren't a patient
unless you've authorized them to do it
your medical records have to be kept
safe and private etc
a journalist saying have you been
vaccinated to a politician
particularly one who's a public figure
has nothing
to do with hipaa and this was not the
only wacky thing that happened here
the republican attacks on dr fauci
continued here is marjorie taylor green
talking about that
the fire fouchy act will bring dr
fauci's by the way
the fire fouchy act this this is a
delusional person
salary down to zero and also will
require the senate to confirm
someone to fill his position right you
see dr
fauci was not elected by the american
people yes as he was not
which is not uncommon for lots of people
in positions of medical significance
chosen to guide our economy he was not
and he
literally says when asked i am not an
economic person
we actually have it's funny she says he
was not chosen to guide our economy
there have been times where dr fauci has
been asked questions during hearings
about
how would you evaluate this guideline
with its economic impact and dr fauci
straight up says
i'm not an economics guy i just make
medical recommendations that's for
economists or politicians or
whoever else to actually talk about and
decide
not chosen to rule over
parents and their children's education
and then that's more of this stuff about
fauci is
uh the democrats and fauci and people
who have
medical opinions are uh in some way
dictatorial overlords over the general
public which is funny because
30 or 40 percent of the country didn't
do a damn thing of all the different
things that were recommended by medical
professionals so very weak
overlordship is what it sounds like and
then lastly marjorie taylor green also
asked about her continued use of the
term china virus and she said it's not
uh it has nothing to do with race you
know you call it the china virus you
suggest
that it's a bio weapon there's no
evidence of any of that
and we're also in the middle of spate of
attacks against
asian americans aren't you just feeding
that uh
pretty easy absolutely not absolutely
not and you're not going to turn this
into something else this is a virus that
killed all kinds of people
it had nothing it has nothing to do with
anyone's race or ethnicity it has
nothing to do with any of that so
well but okay but nationality at minimum
right i mean still calling it the china
virus
not at all okay so there she's just
dismissing that completely out of hand
so
this this is a really gross woman guys
uh as if you couldn't tell of this
completely disgusting person
and whether she was really serious in
her apology about the holocaust stuff
i don't know uh but certainly not
someone who seems to be on the path to
making any more sense recently that's
for sure
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of
our awesome sponsors today one of those
awesome sponsors is
sheath underwear a lot of us know all
too well
about the sticking and the rubbing and
the chafing with traditional
underwear especially this time of year
as the weather is getting warm
sheath underwear have created unique
boxer briefs with
multiple ergonomic compartments in the
front
preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman give
sheath underwear
a shot i've had a great experience i
believe you will too
you can find the link underneath this
video and don't forget to use promo code
pacman for 20 off